three two one Aloha welcome to the Laing
focus Channel and my name is Paul today
we're going to focus on the Hawaiian
language or Olelo Hawaii in Hawaiian
obviously it's a language of Hawaii
wait let me say that again have IE ya
notice there's a glottal stop right
there have IE
of course it's no longer the main
language of Hawaii or even a widely
spoken one only around 18,000 of
Hawaii's 1.4 million people speak it at
home that's according to the u.s. census
of 2010 and there's only one place in
the world where it's the native language
and the main language of the population
the island of niihau
which has a population of only around a
hundred and sixty but even though it's
not widely spoken anymore you do see and
hear a lot of Hawaiian words in Hawaii
you almost definitely hear Aloha
meaning both hello and goodbye but
actually literally means love Aloha
Mahalo
meaning thank you Mahalo and you'll
encounter countless Hawaiian place names
like Waikiki
which means spouting water they is water
Ala Moana
means ocean path or path to the sea ala
is path or way Moana is sea or ocean and
lots of shops and businesses use
Hawaiian words in their names like the
hotel my wife and I recently stayed at
Ohana Malia vy keiki ohana means family
Ohana and this word Kokua means help and
here we see Mahalo again so you can see
that in Hawaii Hawaiian words are
sometimes thrown in when using English
the first Hawaiian people migrated to
the islands from other parts of
Polynesia we don't know when exactly but
the common theory is that the first wave
of migrations came from the Marquesas
Islands as early as 400 seee followed by
a second wave of migration from Tahiti
several centuries later as a result of
that hawaiian shares many similarities
with the markeson and Tahitian languages
despite the geographic distance European
explorers noticed the similarities and
thought that all the languages were
dialects of a single Polynesian language
but at least now there are plenty of
differences too
when British explorer Captain James Cook
first reached Hawaii in 1778 the
population was around 300,000 and they
all spoke Hawaiian American missionaries
soon arrived as well as American
businessmen who established sugarcane
plantations along with them came
diseases such as smallpox which wiped
out much of the native population by
1860 there were only around 60,000
Native Hawaiians and by 1920 only 24,000
many immigrants also came to Hawaii to
work on plantations during this period
from Asian countries like Japan China
and Philippines speaking their
respective languages in 1893 the kingdom
of Hawaii was overthrown with the
intention of annexing it to the United
States in 1896 a law was passed making
English the language of instruction in
Hawaiian schools Hawaiian was not made
illegal to speak but at school children
were disciplined if they spoke Hawaiian
this along with the largely decimated
native population put the Hawaiian
language at serious risk of dying out
over the next century it's a language
that many predicted would be dead by now
but in recent decades there's been more
attention to preserving and promoting
the language in the 1980s new Hawaiian
immersion schools began to be
established including immersion
preschools in 1979 before the
establishment of these schools there
were only around 800 native speakers of
Hawaiian remaining but now according to
the latest u.s. census there were around
18,000 people who speak Hawaiian at home
that doesn't necessarily mean it's their
first language but that they are fluent
speakers and many of them must be among
the people who studied at immersion
schools now let's take a look at some of
the languages key features pronunciation
and orthography Hawaiian is written with
only 8 consonant letters one is a
glottal stop called Akina we heard it
before in Hawaii again notice that
Hawaii also note that certain letters
can represent two different sounds
depending on the dialect or accent but
spelling is now standardized to these
particular letters the letter W can
represent WA or it's more commonly
pronounced these days but it depends on
the speaker and the dialect there
beaches influenced by it as well as on
the surrounding sounds Hawaiian has five
vowels ah eh e o+ kaha Cole a lion
placed over a vowel to indicate that
it's a long vowel there are no consonant
clusters in Hawaiian in other words
there are never two consonants in a row
every syllable ends in a vowel Aloha
Mahalo Ohana etc the stress of a word
usually falls on the penultimate
syllable the second last syllable
here are some basic phrases in Hawaiian
we've seen the first one already Aloha
hello goodbye or love aloha kakahiaka
good morning between the hours of about
6 a.m. to 10:00 a.m.
aloha baqia good day from around 10 a.m.
to 2 p.m.
Aloha Hui Nala good afternoon from
around 2 p.m. to 6 p.m.
Aloha hee hee good evening from around 6
p.m. to 10 p.m. be here oi how are you
make a you I'm good
Waco Inoue what's your name ok Norco we
know my name is Kaia Noah
notice here that Co your and ku my are
two completely different words so you
can't skip the glottal stop in Hawaiian
words all Oh Lou please Mahalo
thank you hey Mikey you're welcome
literally a little thing let's examine
the word order of Hawaiian a little bit
look at the sentence make a you it
doesn't have a verb but notice that the
predicate comes first and the subject
comes second word for word it's good I
this is very common in Austronesian
languages and it immediately reminded me
of Tagalog a language of the Philippines
okay Noah Cowan or word for word it's
personal topic marker ke Noah my name
the subject is Kahlua Noah and the
predicate is okay Noah also it's similar
if the predicate is an adjective
nanika Vahini the woman is beautiful
literally beautiful the woman that's a
full sentence kavaja Nannini means the
beautiful woman and is not a full
sentence there's no predicate it's
simply a noun phrase in Hawaiian noun
phrases if there's an adjective the
comes after the noun whereas in English
it comes before it another example
NUI Kahala means the house is big but
Kahala Nui means the big house if we had
a verb we can see that Hawaiian is VSO
Aloha oh yeah oh I love you word for
word love I you and you can see that
it's vs Oh verb subject object as a side
note ow is the first person singular
subject pronoun yah Oh a is the second
person singular object pronoun
Makemake Oh Evie I want some water
word-for-word want I direct object
marker the water again we see that the
verb comes first followed by the subject
then by the object this word II is a
direct object marker that is used before
common nouns so now we have an idea of
the most basic word order of Hawaiian
articles and determiners we've seen many
nouns preceded by car this is a definite
article there's one more ke ke is used
before nouns beginning with ke e a or o
like bikumu the teacher before nouns
starting with any other letter it's cop
which is more common there's also a
plural definite article na na Kumu that
teachers there's also an indefinite
article hey hey kuma a teacher you can
make the indefinite noun plural by
adding a plural marker mu hey mo Kumu
teachers
similarly there are demonstratives k ya
means this K yo Popo ki this cat k na
means that for things that are near the
listener can Popo key that cat kala
means that for things that are far from
both the speaker and the listener kala
Popo key to make the demonstrative
scleral you can add mo k mo Popo key
these cats
now let's look at possessives oka Evo
Killa that's my dog
over there word for word it's equate of
sentence marker my dog that in the
distance just a quick note about oh this
word comes at the beginning of equative
sentences which are used to specifically
identify something but back to the main
point here this word here is a
possessive meaning mai kakou
possessives in Hawaiian are interesting
because there's more than one version of
each one
kau is an a class possessive a class
possessives are used for things you can
choose whether to possess or not if you
have a dog you probably chose to buy it
and can choose to get rid of it of
course you probably won't because dogs
are our man's best friend but you know
you could the OU class equivalent is
Coco Oh class possessives are mainly
used with nouns that you cannot
choose to possess you inherently possess
them or kukaku he Nakia this is my
sister you can't decide whether you have
a sister or not so this is Oh class
there is an exception for this for
family members below you in your family
tree like children and grandchildren a
class is used a class can be used for
things that you create and I guess you
create your children making them a class
things like body parts are also Oh class
Komaki means my eye : ma means my arm or
my hand etc one caveat is that clothing
and structures that you can enter or
ride are also Oh class as though they
are extensions of your body
okoma Kohala kala that is our house over
there note that with Hawaiian
possessives and Hawaiian personal
pronouns there is first person plural
inclusive in other words we or our
includes the listener and first person
plural exclusive in other words we or
our doesn't include the listener this is
common in Austronesian languages I've
seen something similar in
malay/indonesian and Tagalog this
possessive here kohaku excludes the
listener one more thing which is special
about Hawaiian possessives and personal
pronouns is that there is not just one
set of plural forms there are dual forms
which refer to pairs of people and there
are plural forms which refer to groups
of three or more new Ecola khojali their
house is big this refers to three or
more people's house but if I said Nui
Cola holla it would refer to two
people's house now let's look a little
more closely at verbs you saw before
that there's no verb meaning to be
another important thing to point out is
that verbs are not conjugated for person
or number they stay the same regardless
of the subject he min you I sing
he Minnie oi you sing he Minnie oh yeah
he sings or she sings he Minnie la ku
they sing and so on
tense aspect and mood markers are used
before or after the verb to indicate the
relationship of action to time for
example k + verb + n-- a equals the
present continuous Gahanna neo I am
working a plus verb equals the
perfective aspect showing that an action
is complete often this translates as the
past tense waha know I worked or I have
worked a + verb plus an ax equals the
imperfective aspect which indicates that
an action has not been completed this
often translates as the future tense in
English but can also be used for an
incomplete action in the past
Ahana now I will work or I was working a
plus the verb equals the imperative form
Ahana work it can also function as the
infinitive to work for the negative
imperative you use my Mae Hana don't
work now let's look at a final sentence
in Hawaiian and break it down well hello
a Coue Mirko Mahalo Mahalo Poulet I went
shopping with my friends on Sunday
word-for-word it's perfective marker go
i infinitive shop with my plural marker
friend on the sunday first we see the
perfective aspect marker which shows
that this action is complete again
notice that the sentence is verb initial
the subject comes after the verb next we
see the infinitive form of the verb
meaning to buy or shop next May is a
preposition meaning with there are a few
prepositions in Hawaiian e meaning to on
it or aunt ma meaning on it or at but
not to Mae meaning with oh and ah
meaning of there are two forms here
because there's a distinction between Oh
class and a class and no and not meaning
belonging to again
the first one is Oh class and the second
one is a class next we see the
possessive koten meaning my or mine
which is Oh class friends are treated as
Oh class whereas a class would indicate
a romantic relationship mo is the plural
marker making ha
plural and here's another one of those
prepositions in this case meaning on and
calah Boulet means Sunday car being the
definite article
Hawaiian is a fun language illogical
language and an accessible language it's
not difficult to learn a little bit and
get started speaking fairly quickly
especially thanks to its simple
phonology unfortunately there aren't
that many people to speak with but with
the increasing number of second language
speakers since the 1980s
hopefully Hawaiian will continue to
regain some of its former glory duolingo
actually has a Hawaiian course now and
it's an easy way to experience a little
of this fun language to see if you like
it the question of the day for speakers
of Hawaiian if there are any of you
watching how much do you speak Hawaiian
on a day to day basis and in what
situations and for other people what's
your impression of Hawaiian after seeing
this video leave your comments down
below
be sure to check out liang focus on the
various social media platforms and as
always I want to say a special thanks to
my patreon supporters these people right
here on the screen are my top tier
patreon supporters so many special
thanks to them and to everyone thank you
for watching and have a nice stay
[Music]
you
[Music]